jour où tout a commencé le 13
mars 2020. Comment s'estcole
à la maison?
dans une famille
de quatre enfants.
- Tu as une rencontre
à 1 heure et quart, Mia.
Pelletier gèrent les horaires
et plusieurs rendez-vous
virtuels pour trois de
leurs enfants de 6, 9 et 10 ans.
entraînement.
SÉBASTIEN PELLETIER, père
de Laurent, Collin, Léo et Mia
- Disons que c'est un peu
de tout gérer en même temps.
- Tu sais, des foi
décalé. Fait qu'il y en a
un qui commence à et demie,
je peux être en meeting...
- Depuis surprise
d'Omicron, ils sont comme
des milliers de parents qui
les inconvénients d'un retour
le la semaine prochaine,
ou encore à la garderie pour
le petit Laurent.
EDITH LEMAY, mère de Laurent,
Collin, Léo et Mia
'école ouverte, tu ne
sais pas quel genre de semaine
tu vas avoir. C'est tout
le temps, les mesures, tu sais
jamais; OK, lui, son nez coule,.
Est-ce que les autres doivent
rester à la maison?
Il faut-tu qu'ils s'isolent?
Tu sais, ça change tout
le temps. À la maison, bien au
moins tu sais ce qui s'en vient,
tu peux un petit plus prévoir,
même si tu le sais que ça va
être difficile. C'est toute
cette incertitude-là au
quotidien, pour moi, je trouve
qu'elle use plus que de dire :
bien, regarde, on est à la
maison pour deux semaines, mais
je suis capable de planifier mon
horaire pour les deux prochaines
semaines, puis j'ai l'horaire
des enfants. Je suis capable
de voir ça venir.
- Nous avions rencontré
la famille Pelletier
le 13 mars 2020, le jour où tout
a commencé. Le gouvernement
annonçait alors la fermeture
des écoles et garderies pour
deux semaines.
- Va falloir s'organiser, là,
parce que, là, nous, on essaie
de travailler en même temps, là.
Là, ça fait presque deux ans.Pa
hâte que ça finisse, là.
(rire)
- Les semaines les plus longues
vie, je pense.
- Depuis, Edith Lemay a perdu
son emploi au Cirque du Soleil,
travaillé trois mois en CHSLD
grâce au programme
"Je contribue" et retrouvé
un autre emploi.toucher du bois.
(rire)
Oui, on a été chanceux,
on n'a pas eu la COVID.
- Tu sais, on est
une belle tribu nombreuse.
- Choisir entre le risque lié
aux contacts ou le chaos
prévisible de l'école à
la maison. Léo aussi est
ambivalent, mais pour d'autres
raisons.
que j'aime l'école
à la maison et j'aime, en plus,
être à l'école. J'aime les deux.
- Il n'ybon scénario.
Je pense qu'il y a juste
des scénarios moins pires, puis,
tu sais, le scénario moins pire
pour moi, c'est probablement
le scénario pire pour une autre
personne. Fait que, on va faire
avec, on n'a pas tellement
le choix.
- Comme à l'école, ces deux
parents, qui sont en
télétravail, prévoient
les essentielles périodes
de récréation.
Ici Anne-Louise Despatie,
Radio-Canada, Boucherville.